where did you lie where did you
disappear to recently I haven't seen you
since a lot of people in the comedy
world were like no are just disappeared
he wasn't around for gone for four
months and nobody knew where you weren't
I guess where we were you by yourself
yeah by myself Southeast Asia watch and
you left yourself on your home that's
myself under my drawer changed all my
passwords to oh my oh my [ __ ] mm-hmm
just like stamp a keyboard a bunch of
times and I cut it and paste it and send
it to my friend Lee give me this when I
get back so that you couldn't log I
couldn't get on good Wow
garbage so you couldn't go online at all
did you stop doing the podcast yeah shut
up for four months where do you make it
anything man
you just be true to yourself money will
come to you I hate that's a turn-on
thank you that's a rich parents answer
I've ever heard well I don't know it's
like I have poor taste I don't really
have you know I can live on not that
much I've been poor for a long time so
it's like I don't really need that much
yeah you're like wow if you're just true
yourself money will come but also I
don't have any money
yeah a very small amount of money I'm
not that I can do whatever I want to do
in comedy yeah that's right on shitty
gigs can you turn off your cell phone
were you paying for months of cell phone
bill I turned it off uh uh yeah oh yeah
I'm yeah I didn't do that I was like no
I'm not paying this buck in $20 a month
while I'm gone so there was more
planning in it every day what is it like
[ __ ] this place goodbye yeah anyways I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna purge myself
and did you know did you buy a ticket
and with a return ticket or - I know I
might take it I bought it two days
before I looked at the weather and all
the countries in Southeast Asia and it
was raining everywhere except Myanmar
friends I'm like I'm going to Myanmar
what was the catalyst I just want I want
to see the world and - it's like people
like [ __ ] nipping at me
you have people nipping at you yeah just
like who's nipping and eating things for
me oh don't care for it is that what
happens when you sir get a little bit
more successful you start to find more
more people nipping at you yeah I think
so yeah and then it's like I don't like
this I don't like people recognize me -
it's just like get the [ __ ] out of here
be [ __ ] normal and mostly those see
the world I just want to see the world
who is nipping at you all sorts of
people yeah yeah like oh I don't know
comics like I want to I can't do this on
your show can I do that so what like
manager is an agent it
it was just people wanting to do stuff
yeah yeah yeah it wasn't bad which is
nipping wasn't biting at me right just
like right like asking me for stuff I
just want to be [ __ ] free just be
normal just be left alone
yeah I get it did you tell your may want
to take two weeks ago to a roast battle
and have [ __ ] you know right on that
for two weeks from [ __ ] no money like
I've been on time for that we all do
this right now let me just be atomic
this is what it's like when you don't
care about sneakers is what it's like
rice is good yeah what do we do it right
my investment in sneakers tickets
yeah I'm 20 pairs of Jordan I very
worried if I am Myanmar right whatever
the [ __ ] then what about if I'm gone for
four months and I don't know the sneaker
release date I'm in a milk I miss one no
look I love it I come back to America
looking like corny you know I go to
those he is like last year Jordan each
video got a color spring bottles on his
feet before I didn't realize it was a
spore so has this worked for you this
approach of like I don't want success
and all sudden it comes yeah yeah maybe
or you were it's got better the more
I've just completely focused on just
stand up and and making that as good as
I can and then not focus any unlocked uh
getting known he certainly hasn't helped
you keep a Comedy Central show it has
not you you oh that's right you uh
you're not hosting your own self
I'm I did it that developer welfare
fantastic so you're still getting a
check off of it done plug will occur
when you know it was like I'm going to
do that show as I go already show using
no no it's a different host now I'm like
what but I have a different host of it
is you know everywhere to put it
everybody else came in and was like hey
it's Jim Norton and Sam Roberts there's
Jim Norton and Andrew Schultz and took
white Network but it's my show no no no
it's a great to see you but uh so
tomorrow we just gets back bad and what
still called Jim and Sam but no I'm
gonna be filling in the store are you
changing the format no not at all no I
think there's no sense to do everything
saying everything's gonna look the same
yeah I get Sam's breakfast every day
that's order are going on you're saying
this happened when you're in Southeast
Asia they were pissed off that you went
out there or something like that you
really can't talk about it I want what
you're me yeah did you find out about it
before or after Southeast Asia after
I'll see if I want to go back I got [ __ ]
this I said I'll just tell you this I
found out about right about the same day
I signed a special Netflix okay but that
makes a lot of interesting yeah you
should have signed the TV show first I
did
oh wow okay all right all right all
right all right so there's so there's
that waiting for you when you go back
wait so you went to Southeast Asia
without having the special signed up for
naps just out almost all my money like
yeah I had no money you go to Southeast
I had a little bit left you know a
little bit to like a hundred gram okay
that's so yeah I know I'm trained in
Southeast Asia you're Manny Pacquiao
oh absolutely I think when I got back
I'm like I can live on that for two
years you're good yeah yeah yeah I
thought we're talking about ten no no no
no no yeah I spent about I think forty
to sixty percent of my money on the
special and well uh and then um yeah so
and then the rest you just have like
myself otherwise what to learn so
where'd you stay in stay in hotels or
hostels you just found hostel sound
hostels with social met people not know
what to do you're uncomfortable making
money like you want to be poor I don't
want to be poor
I don't want to be poor but I want to be
famous but do you want to have AI want
to be Daft Punk
that's what I really want if you got to
be the masked comedian yangtze seems
though you don't want to like you're
uncomfortable with the comforts of life
like you don't want to go like if you're
going to go to Southeast Asia
yeah you're gonna stay in a hostel
because that's what you've always done
you're not going to stay in though now
I've never stayed in a hostel what if
you used to do
hotels here's what here's the joy of
hostels don't gross they're disgusting
yeah that's not the joy the joy is you
meet other travelers yeah you don't meet
anybody in the hotel oh yeah yeah yeah
me too the people you get social what is
it it do what Oh what what temple I've
never heard of that I mean none of them
have an ego because they're also a toss
but that has any backstory there yeah
no one has any backstory they they are
only the sum of how long you've been
traveling yeah I've only been gone a
week you've been going for weeks
Wow I look up to you right where's your
good there's no like Oh what do you do
back at home or your comic oh I got some
stuff that I want you oh not of that
none of that I got recognized maybe five
times in four months Ryan made you try
to do comedy out there no I went to one
show up Phnom Penh Cambodia that was
pretty fun yeah yeah they have a little
scene in the Asia oh yeah yeah yeah you
been out there I went to Singapore
Malaysia ah that's great little [ __ ]
college things they bring out Americans
you're cool you actually were you on the
show you've watched you're lost I will
say this the AMA tea means way more out
there way more because you you can't
criticize the government or anything in
society on like news or radio or
anything so oh you know by the time we
get up at night into our show they
already heard the jokes about our Kelly
here they saw them on the Twitter the
memes Instagram all that they don't get
any of that [ __ ] Malaysia so when they
go see you and I make about video
exactly so when they go see and you and
they say you do a joke and [ __ ] and
you're making fun of the the governor
you making fun of the President
the way that their faces react is
completely different because they've
never heard anything what I made a joke
about mather like do not make any jokes
up now and I did and I was like uh I was
talking about our government and I was
like no but new mail comes in America
and murders all of them and I was like
oh like that's problem ow it's okay more
worry don't like after seeing that kid
who got killed in North Korea that some
weird [ __ ] could happen in a foreign
government
you got worried but that's faceless
worried North Korea is different the
actor is a real [ __ ] totalitarian
regime right and they don't get
everything that killing you never
exactly you can I got a bad stuff - if I
kill your hair looks career is already
like well we're out we don't care about
your we're not going to make friend
America I know the worst off yet is
lashed so at what point you decide to
come back I came back four months you
were gone
about four months yeah that's a huge
amount of time yeah so by the end of it
you're in the hospital they're like oh
how long you been you're like four
months
yes Mary what I got a lot of people I've
got a lot of dual travelling between
three months it was a pretty normal one
a lot of people six months in a year I
met a girl from Italy we're going
five years Jesus and she finds jobs and
other places and just keeps going try me
no escape is in there
some of us running away so let's see
what some officials like I can keep
seeing the world well yeah I'm not
getting back to some [ __ ] the boss
were you unshaven or did you keep
yourself grooms the whole time I shaved
my head and my beard and I like that and
I let it go yeah cuz I don't I don't
know this haircut situation going to be
out there I did find an occasional like
other traveler with like a razor and I'm
like or like a [ __ ] like he's a menace
if again I'm like I'm so [ __ ] hot it
was great man it was very amazing
so the [ __ ] it all the responsibility
within I know two three four weeks just
faded off me there was nothing to do
nowhere to be
you tell your agent or manager whoever I
told them only be gone for a while just
a while I was like cover for me all
right when I got back I don't know
I'll be back for the next season of the
show don't worry I won't let you down
was it and then you know yeah you're
right this is still the girl you rush
back for nothing yeah what about uh what
about like purpose yeah did you feel
lost without perfect question that's a
good class yeah yeah yeah no I felt real
lonely at first but no the purpose was
seeing stuff so every day brought like a
new adventure okay just taking the bus
finding out how to take a bus in a
country where no one speaks English is
amazing going to the market and just
find some sunflower seeds we snuck in so
fun and cool how long did it take you to
not see oh I would assume in the
beginning I know for me in the beginning
I would feel like like useless I go
waste like what am i doing like I have
to be productive I can't you the purpose
just how long did it take for you to
lose that it took um it took a little
while to get like a certain level of
that and then it took about a month and
a half I was on a beach in Cambodia and
I was like oh there's literally nothing
to do here it's not even a temple on
supposed to go see or [ __ ] you know a
train around the city they're supposed
to do the cool thing to do here there's
nothing so then it just sat and read and
accepted like no time right that's why
bank holidays are dope because nobody's
working I could chill if I know you're
not trying to make a new spirit upon me
you're exactly the way oh wait you're
chilling okay everybody's already cool
stop don't know
right we gotta agree to all shut it down
Ramadan yeah we got to do career ramadan
allah in one month a year everybody
agrees otherwise you get ahead of me
Kevin Hart's got 40 movie I gotta hurt
I alright alright got the double special
okay I got to do something yeah so has
that changed your perspective now a lot
of stuff yeah like do you find yourself
less sort of like oh I gotta do this I
gotta do that yeah I'm doing great man
I'm making my [ __ ] art a little
special double negatives are now on
Netflix but be more of an artist now no
but I just mean like you know I hate
saying that with comedy but like I'm
just comfortable doing what I do I'm
right embarrassed to call it art it is
because of dick jokes or doesn't like
makes it I don't know but we are some
naked [ __ ] in the [ __ ] gallery right
we care and we just stare it or we go
are looking at mom they are gross like
there's way more artistic merit to what
we do yes I'm so embarrassed I think
only as comics the minute you take
anything seriously somebody is there to
tell you what an [ __ ] yeah that's it
we are to work yeah we're you a year oh
yeah maybe we're so true artist we don't
even call it art within another name for
today oh just insecure we're so limited
and we don't know what a call that
that's problem yeah and so what point do
you decide like trying to go home um for
two days in I was like I gotta get our
shoes mistake she's like I'm lonelier
than it ever been in my life I got to
turn my phone back on yeah why don't
have it with me right I there was no way
to connect to any but there's only like
emails of like hey I need this motif did
you go to an airport and buy a ticket
yeah Wow
yeah or go on like a computer and just
like buy a ticket there yeah kind of you
know Internet campaign you're Jenna cafe
or sometimes they had a bit like some
hospitals that had a computer you could
use shitty old one did you notice how
often people are on their phones when
you had none yeah man and I noticed too
much I mean I had people making fun of
me too like let's get a Facebook group
so we can all I go on this hike together
oh my god I'm not on that like you
[ __ ] idiot
and then I had this girl's Danish girl
excuse me Danish woman uh yeah he's got
a specified let's do there yeah I seen
Lydia yes it was like up to three hours
one night she goes he I saw I mean I was
just checking my Facebook feed for three
hours now I'm dead tired on his hike and
you were are you above me in his bunk
bed sleeping peacefully
yeah
just up for nothing not doing work or
getting it just [ __ ] checking my feed
you talk a lot on the trip know what
why'd you do it then
like I get the art the art stuff but
that's usually just fun offered a you're
thinking that immediately but we are so
in this like our inexperienced and I was
like I wanna be that guy well I get laid
without stand up anymore I don't know
how to get laid if I go girl stages but
he really funny doesn't in or like some
we reaching out on Instagram I kissed
it's like well that seems like a sign
yeah you're saying can you write to your
number on this napkin doesn't work and
I'm going up I have nothing I have no
strength I'm just some [ __ ] Jew right
yeah wish no strengthen New York also
but not over there right right yeah
nothing and so [ __ ] and I'm like Oh what
are you huh oh and then some German guys
I have a motorcycle walk to the ride and
you're like [ __ ] I don't have anything
anymore I think it laid out there I got
laid a couple times but not what you're
used to not what I'm used to and I was
really like I'm not getting hookers
anymore I'm done I'm not doing out here
I'm talking normal girls or nothing and
it was a lot of times it was nothing a
lot of times it was not and did you try
and strike out I tried once I got
thirsty to a guy they got embarrassing
how big how much it was just like I was
just got to the point where I was like I
like this girl and pie that I met Erna
and some like monasteries monastery like
meditation retreat and she was cool man
she was cool she was a bad girl and I
liked her and they're like mister like
cools I can't let's go back and [ __ ] no
talents let's do this one ducky which is
like are you kidding me you're
disgusting ah one makes a move like that
wait you said because adverb a them I
wrote I think I wrote something to her
I'll tell hawk you yeah just like do you
know just like let's go for it and just
know you actually get fun to hang out
with and like we write kiss your condo
dammit man you're used to people who
already know who you are coming to you
for and I just pushed so [ __ ] hard
but yeah you're not wrong
they're on us right now I want to think
it just happened yeah I met this guy at
a retreat we just ended up [ __ ] you
wanted to stamp in a pre oh yeah your
tears on the [ __ ] yeah yeah dude
honor does that usually work for you
yeah sometimes usually it's like it's
like yeah I don't know how it happened
like how did it happen well I got this
text and he was like we should go [ __ ]
now serendipity basically yes okay Don
it yeah you know sometimes the great the
good ones just fall into your lap I
don't know how it happened after I don't
know I just just out here in New York
people like it's cool right yeah so so
okay so you're not [ __ ] yeah but
you're seeing the world I'm getting hard
too it was hard to difficult concentrate
oh yeah because you've roommates are you
you can't check off that much right oh I
stop jerking off in August last August
yeah I think you'll mind if we might
have spoken to it but I figured you must
have started jerking off again though
you have another job sense nope August
third wet dream did you have any
nocturnal emissions while you were
traveling I don't think so
I mean I know I [ __ ] two girls the
whole time yeah
consistently or this is one night though
one was the one-night stand and then
another was like five straight days in
Bali so you're talking about six comes
in a four month period I could do that
I'm not gonna lie like [ __ ] that much
what what is good for me once a week is
totally yeah but after the one week like
I would I was in two weeks and then
about three and a half weeks I'm about
your boat twice a week twice a week and
then it gets to be like our noodle
release or it's also knowing you could
do it yes totally it's like being a
chick it's like they don't need a [ __ ]
when they know they can call you
jerk-off - right I don't jerk off you
never go but I don't have a rule again
what do these are doing I don't have a
high sex or I think it's propecia so I'm
sure like that I just don't need a yeah
when you're [ __ ] once you to raise a
week if this is the weird like kind of
primal thing about it if it's different
girls I can [ __ ] way more if it's the
same girl I'll tap out - oh really
exactly times so I think you're a sex
addict if you want to have sex anymore
that yeah yeah I mean once or twice a
week I can get I get behind that that
mate that's I think that's normal but
once I was like people understand effect
you're boring to me now we've already
[ __ ] what else are we going to do and
I don't need
to go like kinky like not even is that
kinda [ __ ] yeah it's like it's cool but
to not have any orgasms at all while
you're travelling was hard man and then
you're trying to like sleep and the
mines wanted to crazy sexual thoughts
and then a [ __ ] the bunk bed next to
you this some [ __ ] German just
tagging a girl oh wait you didn't just
talk see I would Turk off to that I was
like normally would why would I you what
why don't you're gone even it doesn't
make me social makes you less social so
especially when I'm a jerk off a little
and not for you I could I just tried let
me go a year we tried talking to see if
I can go the whole year also where we're
11 months in yeah yeah no real value
yeah what come party you know Indiana
everybody come over the coming milking
of Ari Shaffir so a lot of this is is
really a self-improvement huh yeah maybe
some of us sir how do I become more
social how do I get these things out of
my life is socializing tough for you
yeah and that helped a lot out there
yeah that helps a lot because then it
became like I don't know how to like
meet some even on the train or anything
like how do you need a prism yeah but
then it's like you go out there and and
you're at the communal breakfast where
it's like a free you know shitty little
nothing breakfast and go out there
people so boring it's not even a boring
thing I think when you have some sort of
social anxiety it's just the fear the
fear and it's like I wish they would
come to me yeah but I wish I would come
up to them yeah and the crazy to say
dude I relate to this sometimes I'll
force myself just to talk to some you
know to walk down or something like that
and once you do it's not hard even
though careful woman if you're just like
hey what are you drinking there and
she's a goddess smoothie in your head
like a sigh II like Phil they want to
connect to work in humans yeah it's a
city to shut everybody down
yeah to worry all you do is watch
Netflix specials like double negative
alone and you don't have to pay for
friends over so so what was the what was
the when did you decide to go home
because you this was kind of playing it
by ear the entire time yeah could have
been two weeks could have been two days
it was four months yeah I wrote a letter
I remembered uh did anybody know where
you were specifically like where people
worried about you yes no person no what
kind of luck did you you barracks we
have a
yeah I got brother two sisters why you
did it to your family I just didn't want
my know what's going I only looking for
me G time you were going on a trip down
yeah that's all I'd be gone okay they're
like we need to my manager I need your
number I don't have a number because I
need a way again I started a new email
address just for people I met out there
but you didn't give it to anybody back
here no nobody and so then and so the my
matter is I need your number like you
can have it's not acceptable like if it
makes you feel better my mom doesn't
have any way to get touching me too and
she goes that does make me feel better
what if your mama died while you were
gone yeah what if then when I go to home
I'd mourn them right I guess so and
you're gonna mourn you're gonna more to
be better she's dead yeah you had what
amounted more months with a mom yeah
exactly true exactly she's like your
heart yeah I think 11 are you about
numbers Mike explain to me the emergency
that I would need to be home for what do
you mean you mean someone dying I can't
help that right yeah by guess the
argument might be like if she had you
know some kind of terminal illness you
get to go see her before she goes I
don't have that with us Mars never like
it you need a blood transfusion and only
your son Ari has the same type of blood
blood sensors in the only one yeah the
only one you out there just trying to
bang but what we see certain girls that
Danish girls at Rio grocers and New
Zealand girls and uh so why do you
decide to come home when I wrote a
letter to my to my to my manager I was
like oh I remember they wanted to do
this uh this um show at Third Man
Records for there was a festival down
there awesome at the end of April and
they wanted to do it does not happen
show a storytelling show and I remember
that it was like I was coming home late
May for the taping of the show and I was
like oh yeah you wanted to do dad to
YouTube April so I wrote a letter I
found their address on Google Maps I
remember sort of what block it is and I
you know made it bigger and like clicked
on it like okay that's their address
sent her a letter and I was like hey if
you still want to do that show I forgot
about it completely if you still want to
do it put it on the website I'll talk
and check it I'll be home and then uh
also key yeah because you can't say like
write me back
yeah so you just have to you wait a week
there's a letter to get there or
whatever and you just start checking
your website to see if you have a Wild
West Comedy Festival website and see oh
there's like that I'm going home
whatever going back to work yeah stop
then saw my parents first surprised
Wow where they freaking out oh yeah I
plus my two sisters and their kids were
all there so it's just like I just
walked in like what the [ __ ]
yeah were you paying yeah I said I sent
her some flowers once with our ham safe
right right you know that's right you
can touch with me so empathetic thing
deal yeah are you gonna do it again okay
ma'am you are right when I do my next
special beat disappear again and I don't
my work
I'll [ __ ] business yeah I'm inspired
then you disappear no not necessarily
disappear but I'm inspired by like the
disconnect from the phone yeah I think
about a lot but I'm too [ __ ] to
disconnect from it well you know also
you're connected so it's hard to get off
yeah you know I just did one over the
weekend yeah and this is part of the I
think it's a first step because I'm the
same way about the phone like when I
ended up buying a new iPhone because of
course but my old iPhone was [ __ ]
the bed and I was like I want to get you
get a flip phone I want to get like or
maybe maybe I'll go blackberry that's a
little less can I go too you know but uh
then I just end up buying an iPhone but
I found there it is just a shitty phone
but I uh I went back to using an iPod
I'm instead of using like a streaming
music so what you on that [ __ ] you do I
have to load up your music yeah but I
have to have spin wheel yeah oh hell
yeah every row babies right baby driver
use it but I have to buy the music cuz
like I want this out Oh hold on no you
don't why didn't you have to buy the
music when you didn't have to back there
my favorite thing I exported all my
iTunes until like a new like I got the
updated thing and they were like it said
like you have 630 7426 songs you have
one purchase all I know is were not CDs
you imported oh man I see people Best
Buy with CDs what do you do use is free
the patient progress yeah no I didn't I
didn't I never downloaded why did when
Napster first came out I used it but
then after once iTunes came out I never
downloaded free music ever one way to go
yes but I downloaded like but it was it
was it was kind of an amazing experience
listening to new music on an iPod and
with the whole album listen tell them
not to worry about like if I'm in good
service I put it in our stereo and like
the sound is noticeably different
because you're not streaming right I
mean it's got to be compressed it's yeah
because it's a file it doesn't ring good
interesting so there's an app for the
phone that you can get that will shut
down whatever apps you want for X amount
hold on because I look for this before I
went got a flip phone at me about this
and she said that you can it just locks
it for you
the woman who died in the bathroom yeah
real protect like one who's what no no
but she's just like you know she's a
really great worker you know she's like
a woman or so it's unbelievable ww
yeah what what would when they do you
know for real I'm like blown away by it
but it's one of those things where like
yeah maybe I could maybe I would do that
maybe I shut down hood for one like that
and all I found was after a certain
amount of hours you said it's whatever
it is yeah it'll set off an alarm saying
you've gone over your time but then you
just show off the alarm and keep going I
need one that said you're done yeah
you're done now yeah yeah so you can
click like oh I really need to do this
like what you should have thought of
that before you use up all your time we